bienvenidos Ahora quiero mostrarles otra
manera de describir vectores y después
haremos el problema de movimiento de
proyectiles usando esta nueva anotación
Esto es para que ustedes conozcan las
diferentes maneras o notaciones de
vectores y no se confundan si ven que su
profesor usa una anotación diferente de
la que hemos visto hasta el momento
cuando vimos la notación de unidades
vectoriales aprendimos a expresar
vectores usando sus componentes en x y
en y digamos que tengo aquí un vector a
que tiene los elementos y usando la
notación vectorial la describo así dos y
más 3 j
esta notación también se conoce como
notación ingeniería otra forma de
expresar esto es con pico paréntesis o
la notación par ordenado de manera que
este vector a
lo podemos expresar con pico paréntesis
el elemento en y
coma el elemento de j y cerramos con un
pico paréntesis como si fuera una
coordenada o un par ordenado solamente
que con los picor paréntesis ustedes
saben que se trata de vectores ahora
resolvemos uno de los problemas
anteriores con una variación ahora vamos
a resolver la segunda parte del problema
en el problema anterior teníamos una
pelota de béisbol Bueno vamos a dibujar
aquí nuestros ejes coordenados
un poquito más derechos
y teníamos una Ay Dios Okay
una pelota de béisbol
Aquí vamos a golpear esta pelota se
encuentra a una altura de cuatro pies
y es golpeada esta pelota con una
velocidad inicial
de 120 pies por segundo y va a tener un
ángulo con respecto a la horizontal de
30 grados
bueno está horizontal no está muy
horizontal ustedes Disculpen Aquí más o
menos Ahí está
entonces lo que queremos es saber o
bueno lo que vimos en el problema
anterior era ver si esta pelota con
estos datos iniciales podía superar una
barda que se encontraba
a una distancia de
350 pies
pies
y que tenía una altura de 30 pies
más o menos Esta es nuestra barda
y con una altura de 30 pies
del problema anterior vimos que con
estas condiciones pues no alcanzaba a
superar esta barra sin embargo en esta
segunda parte del problema nos indican
que además sopla una racha de viento
hacia la derecha con una velocidad de 5
pies
por segundo
justo en el momento en el que estamos
bateando o estamos golpeando la pelota
entonces Bueno podemos comentar en
complicaciones de calcular exactamente
cuánto acelera la pelota el viento su
resistencia al aire etcétera Pero para
mantener simple este problema vamos a
tomar este dato que lo vamos a agregar a
la componente en x de la velocidad
inicial incrementando las cinco pies por
segundo ahora vamos a hacer lo mismo que
hicimos en el vídeo anterior para
resolver el problema pero ahora vamos a
usar una nueva anotación esta nueva
anotación que vimos nuestro función
posición con respecto al tiempo que es
un vector va a ser igual a la posición
inicial
que es un vector todos estos son
vectores más
la velocidad inicial
multiplicada por el tiempo más
dos veces perdón la aceleración
por el tiempo al cuadrado dividido entre
entonces de nuevo vemos nuestros
vectores uno por uno nuestra posición
inicial
ahora con la nueva anotación pues
tenemos solo los elementos en x Perdón
en Y entonces con nuestra anotación
inicial tenemos cero Porque no tenemos
componente en x y el valor que tenemos
es 4 en Y entonces 0,4
nuestro
vector velocidad inicial
va a ser igual a
bueno usando las funciones
trigonométricas tenemos el elemento de
la posición o el elemento vertical de
esta
velocidad que es 120 por el seno de 30
grados y en esta parte la componente en
x
es 120 coseno de 30 grados
así que bueno expresamos esta posición
velocidad inicial la componente en x
120 por coseno de 30 grados es el coseno
de 30 grados es igual a raíz de 3 entre
2 120 entre 2 es 60
multiplicado por raíz de 3
y la componente en y son 120 seno de 30
grados seno de 30 grados es igual a un
medio la mitad de 120 es 60
Este es mi vector velocidad inicial como
ven Esta anotación es más chiquita es
más breve nos ahorra espacio al escribir
nuestro vector aceleración es la
aceleración de la gravedad como vimos en
el video pasado la aceleración de la
gravedad Pues solo tiene su componente
hacia abajo y en el sistema inglés la
aceleración de la gravedad es de 32 pies
por segundo al cuadrado 10 y es menos
porque la dirección basa hacia abajo
entonces aquí no tenemos componente en x
y tenemos la componente vertical que es
de menos 32
aquí están nuestros vectores lo
sustituimos en la fórmula
nuestro
vector posición en el tiempo
es igual a este vector posición inicial
0,4
más
y tiempo que multiplica al vector 60
raíz de 3,6
0 más
t cuadrada entre 2 que multiplica el
vector aceleración que es 0, -32
aquí Bueno una cuestión que tenemos que
agregar estos era del sistema anterior
la velocidad inicial además de este
vector velocidad tenemos que agregarle
estos cinco pies por segundo del viento
en la componente x entonces en esta
parte
voy a agregar
60 maestras de tres más cinco que es lo
del componente del viento y ahora sí
vamos a simplificar toda esta ecuación
de nuevo escribimos la
función posición en el tiempo
es bueno este vector queda igual 04 T
0,4 más
60 por raíz de 3 + 5 toda esta operación
me va a quedar
más o menos
voy a multiplicar
esta operación todo esto me da una
cantidad que yo voy a redondear a 109
Entonces es 109 lo multiplico por T
coma 60
de más
Este término multiplicado por cero queda
en cero y menos 32 entre 2 es igual a
menos 16 multiplicado por t al cuadrado
y aquí queda nuestra fórmula lo que
vamos a hacer es ahora sí que acomodar
los términos que corresponden por
ejemplo vamos a sumar todos los
elementos que son en x que aquí nada más
tenemos estos y en la siguiente
parte de nuestra canción va a ser los
elementos
en y que son estos
Así que nuevamente
vector posición va a ser igual ahora
cero más ciento nueve t más cero que de
igual a 109 T
y ahora voy a escribir en otro color lo
que es en y 4 + 60 t menos 16 Entonces
es 4 + 60 * t - 16 de cuadrada
y así queda mi función
Ahora quiero conocer cuánto tiempo tardó
esta pelota con estas nuevas condiciones
en recorrer los 350 pies que es el
componente en x Así que este término
lo voy a despejar para que sea igual a
350 la distancia Entonces voy a
escribirlo de esta parte de este lado
109 t igual a 350
t es igual a 350 entre 109
y esto nos da la operación que los
invito a que lo hagan ustedes en su
calculadora de tres punto dos segundos y
ahora vamos a sustituir este tiempo en
esta parte de la ecuación
en la componente x para saber la altura
de esta pelota en este momento en el
tiempo entonces es 4 + 60 * 3.2 menos 16
por 3.2 al cuadrado es igual a 4 + 192
menos 164 y toda esa operación es igual
a 32 perdón sí 32
entonces
esos son 32 pies
en la posición x por lo que mi vector
posición en el tiempo de 3.2 segundos
va a ser igual
a la parte de x o a la distancia
recorrida 350 y en y va a ser igual a 32
pies
como nuestra barda mide 30 pies y la
altura de la pelota en ese momento es 32
pies Pues en este momento si le pasa si
logra pasar por encima de nuestra barda
y bueno con esto pues podemos concluir
que efectivamente esta incremento en el
viento ayuda a nuestra pelota a superar
esta banda Espero no vernos confundido
mucho y nos vemos en el siguiente video